first message was pimpin ain't easy but
somebody's got to do it
now's my first master church meeting you
have to church me your gift can be
anything you can't look at it as simply
running jumping singing and dancing
rise and shine it's expresso time what's
up belief nation it's Evan I am sick but
I still believe in you and this channel
is still designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
cup of tea
and sip on today's message find your
gift over to you Eric Thomas also if you
want to know what Eric Thomas and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 254 confident series where
every day for the next 254 days I will
send you a morning video for free to
help you build your confidence the link
to join is in the description below even
if you my closest friend I have
boundaries
if you gonna get to the next level
you're gonna have to give up something
right what I've been telling you to get
that gold get that dream and I'm just
been telling you driving and driving and
driving and driving what I've been
talking about is consistency
[Music]
when did you know hey this is something
different about me I can really speak
here this is something unique freshman
year in college don't laugh
alright freshman year in college me and
my boys start like this like Christian
like organizations or every Tuesday
Thursday and Sunday we'd speak now they
didn't let me speak initially okay
because I was a high school dropout
rough around the edges like I wasn't
really polished right and so but here's
a good thing is you know you stay home
was a gift so we did it every Tuesday
Thursday Sunday so at some point the
guys couldn't make the appointment so so
I was like always the host of the show
so when they didn't show up yes they
like when we bring in surah so to speak
I'm like nah no you're not I'm hosted so
this is my shot right here the best of
villain ability is availability right
everyone there Trey wedding there I'm
like finally three four months into it
I'm like I'm no I mean it cuz they got
hair did I don't you know
and my first message was pimpin ain't
easy but somebody's got to do it that's
my first master Church meeting you have
to church me i pimpin ain't easy but
somebody's got to do it I said no laugh
but but this is how I knew I had
something because people were like yo
nobody's ever and so I talked about how
the devil is trying to pimp us and and
you know and I just took that whole
angle and my second message just blew up
was how many licks does it take to get
to the center of a sucker you know and
so everybody was just like yo brother
it's different like this is not a normal
preacher it's not a normal delivery the
energy is kind of different
so while adults weren't really fooling
with me a lot of guys who were like oh
we only do that Church stuff like we
don't do that kind of stuff we're not
into that and what was unique about and
I'm glad you asked nobody's ever asked
me this
what was unique is that we did at the
bell tower which was in the center of
the campus so you had to pass it to go
anywhere so it's cast like you I wasn't
coming to no spiritual event but I would
hear that loud voice in that passion and
I heard Pippin Pippin
are you that church you know so they
would just walk over like yeah
talk about pimping and easy and and it
was at that point when I saw non church
regular people jeans t-shirts coming by
and when I would speak stop I was like
yo e you got you got something yeah you
got something now I've got a special
bonus clip that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that question today I
want to know what is your true gift for
me it's helping entrepreneurs it's
making videos it's why I still get up
and do this even though I'm sick because
I want to show up for you guys I want
you to have content every day to help
you believe in yourself more and so I
want to know what is your gift let me
know put it in the comments below
your gift can be anything you can't look
at it as simply running jumping singing
and dancing but I tell you one thing
your gift is the thing that you do the
absolute best with the least amount of
effort for me it was comedy so once you
identified then that's that's the
beginning of it but there's a lot of
work to do even after you identify your
gift you know you can believe you're
something all you want but if you don't
work towards it you just sitting there
it's gonna be empty in high school you
sort of were known for doing something
in the morning can you sort of tell us
this talent that you showed as a high
schooler well in high school I uh I
started doing the morning announcements
you know usually have a little
announcement in between first and second
period which tells you what the day's
events are and I had my buddy Steve ball
dekosky who was the senior class
president was trying to figure out a way
to sell senior class t-shirts which was
our big fundraiser to get to do some fun
thing at the end of the year and so he
enlisted my help and and my buddy Bart
and we basically started writing skits
that we would announce throughout the
school where we would make fun of
teachers students do assumed character
voices everything and something that
really shouldn't have been allowed and
in school but it became so successful
that teachers would come up to me like
when eat are you doing another
announcement and so that was kind of
that was kind of the beginning steps I
took in in thinking that I wanted to do
comedy if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you up or that would be like a
little beacon if you want more Eric
Thomas I highly recommend the top-50
rules video we did on him the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there you will not I work me Oh
Joe Jett he will not work me and your
bid Lee you will not work me